one of the more interesting schools of
ancient Greek and later Roman philosophy
is that called cynicism and there are
debates about whether this is even a
coherent school at all whether it's
origin stories are historically
veritical or not there's all sorts of
interesting matters associated with this
and you know the cynic impulse has
transformed over time the meaning of the
very word has changed but there's still
lots of traces of what it was that the
original cynics were quite interested in
and advocating for in terms not just of
philosophy as an academic discipline but
as a way of living a way of orienting
oneself towards the world oneself other
people Society 30 so it's definitely a
school worth studying but it presents
numerous challenges for people who want
to get into it particularly if you're
studying outside of the Traditional
Academy and engaging in what we call
self-directed study so that's why I'm
producing this video to provide a sort
of guide and some ideas about where you
can go some
matters that you might have otherwise
not encountered or overlooked and
hopefully this will be helpful for those
who want to begin studying this
interesting tradition of philosophy and
for those who've already gone a little
ways into it you might learn a few
things along the way that you didn't
already know you know not anything that
I'm really providing you with but I'm
drawing on a lot of other Scholars who
certainly know the literature far better
than I do and we'll talk about them in
time
I think it's an entirely fair question
to begin with not just for the cynics
but for any philosopher why should I
bother studying this stuff what am I
going to get out of it what is the
importance what is the you know uh meat
the juice whatever you want to call it
that you're going to get out of it and I
begin by saying well you know within the
history of philosophy we typically
classify the cynics as some people call
a minor Socratic school that is it
supposed to have had its origins in this
really important guy Socrates who didn't
just Inspire Plato and then you know of
course lead to Plato's the famous
student Aristotle but also other
branches and and movements in schools of
philosophy which would include the
cynics who then lead to the stoics big
important School as well
uh you know there's debate about how
Socratic cynicism really is and we'll
get to that in a bit but that might be
one reason why you want to study it
you've heard of this Socrates guy maybe
you've read about him in Plato you want
to get some you know a different flavor
of where Socrates way of life and
Doctrine could go because antisthenes
was a student and friend of Socrates and
he's often credited as being the
beginning point of the cynic school you
know they've also had significant
influence and interest for later
philosophers I don't think that you can
adequately understand
historically what's going on in stoicism
without also looking at and
understanding cynicism to some degree in
part because Zeno was a student of
karates the third you know supposed
skolarc of the cynics and because other
stoics seem to been quite attracted to
cynicism Epictetus as a prime example
um you know there's a number of
interesting interpretations of the cynic
school you can't say that it was one big
unified we must all follow the master
sort of school which was you know the
case for say epicureanism where they
would say you know ipsa Dixit as Cicero
makes fun of them the master has said
right and they celebrated his birthday
and things like that the cynics are at
the other end of the spectrum and so it
can be kind of interesting just to see
the motley character of these people but
then I think another main reason you
might want to study them would be the
ideas that they not only put forward but
in the way that they lived in the things
that they said and the behaviors and
choices that they made
show a kind of commitment and you know
I'll just mention a few of these we
often say in our culture speaking truth
to power well you know the cynics were
some of the early speaking truth to
power kind of people actually speaking
truth to anybody who would listen really
and this is called parisia frankness of
speech and the cynics were very well
known for engaging in this but it didn't
mean just saying anything whatsoever
there were other ideas that were quite
important you know another one is
debasing the currency that is rejecting
social norms as being conventional and
not truly natural for us human beings
and doing things to subvert them
so that's an important idea cynic
shamelessness you know being willing to
do things that break with social
conventions because uh you know they
lead to a simpler way of life or happier
way of life or a more natural way of
life including even having sex out in
public for you know the cynic couple
karates and hipparchia but doing all
sorts of other things like that as well
and then you know another really central
idea is this term ponos which means toil
or labor or difficulty the cynics
embraced this and thought that you
needed to toughen yourself up both
bodily and psychologically by engaging
deliberately in toil you couldn't avoid
it because sooner or later you're gonna
have to do it so may as well do it in a
deliberate way so I think those are some
good initial reasons reasons to dive
into this philosophy and I'll just add
one other one the cynics are a fun
school I mean unless you're kind of
prudish but most of us aren't and so I
think you'll have a lot of fun reading
the things that they actually say and
thinking about their crazy sometimes
examples
now with this school we have a number of
very practical questions about the
school itself and the text that we would
discover it through and you know like
the stoics and to a lesser extent the
epicureans because we do have some
things from epicurus himself we're in a
bit of a quandary you know the early
cynics we know things about them but we
don't have their actual writings and so
just to give you an example well several
examples so antisthenes this is coming
from diogenes Laertes
diogenes is is nice in part because he
gives us listings of what these people
are supposed to have written and so I'm
not going to read all of these but he
says
antistani's writings are preserved in 10
volumes the first includes A Treatise on
expression or styles of speaking Ajax or
the speech of Ajax Odysseus or
concerning Odysseus a defense of orestes
or concerning forensic writers isography
or lysius and a Socrates so those are
rhetoricians right a reply to the speech
of the Socrates entitled without
whiteness and then it you know jumps
forward I'll just read uh the third
volume the third volume our treaty sees
on the good of Courage of law or of a
commonwealth of law or of goodness and
Justice of freedom and slavery of belief
of the guardian or on Obedience of
Victory and economic work I mean you
know all over the map right and there's
many other ones as well and you know we
see these listings in the entries for
others as well
um and you know so we've lost every one
of these texts unfortunately you know
diogenes himself is supposed to have
written these
um kephalian ichthius Jack Daw portal
house so those are all kind of you know
obscure things the Athenian demos okay
now we're talking politics right the
Republic the art of ethics on wealth on
love theodorus hipsius aristocus on
death letters and then he wrote
tragedies as well so I don't need to go
any further into this but we see that
there's a large literature that may have
existed probably existed and we don't
have access to it anymore so how do we
in fact get to these um
cynic texts well
um
diogenes Laertes who I just mentioned is
one of the very important authors
because in his lives of the philosophers
in book six he is going to give us lives
of antisthenes diogenes monemos Ona
secretus krates
metricles hipparchia manipus and
mendemos and he'll also talk about Xeno
and how Zeno was trained by krates among
others and he'll talk about another
important
stoic philosopher who kind of goes off
and does his own thing Ari Stone who
some people think is influenced by
cynicism so what he's giving us in this
in in these lives are the sayings and
the Deeds of these philosophers and then
he gives us you know the book listings
but he also tells us other things that
they thought right so that's a really
important Source text for learning who
these cynics were another that's quite
important is xenophon's symposium at
least if we want to know more about this
guy
antisthenes so you know xenophon was in
this circle of Socrates so he knew
antisthenes and all these other people
and he recorded Socratic dialogues so
that's another important uh text the the
Symposium or banquet sometimes it's
called and then after that we start
getting into
other later authors Epictetus as I
mentioned is quite important he has an
entire chapter in his discourses about
the cynics which is quite laudatory of
them Lucian of samasata who has a number
of different texts that
talk about the cynics there's several in
particular that you would probably want
to read and then there's lots of other
authors in ancient times who weren't
cynics who you know we learn about the
cynics from Seneca is helpful with
respect to Demetrius who we'll talk
about in a bit Plutarch and his lives
will recount things about the cynics and
so there's you know quite a few authors
that we might want to look at there are
some later texts and so this is kind of
like the stoics where you know the the
main body of literature we have are what
we call late stoics not even middle or
early stoics well it's the same way with
cynicism we have this guy Dio chrysostom
who himself was a cynic at least for a
while and wrote a number of orations
which sometimes have to do with diogenes
and sometimes just you know part what's
going on in his life and that's
particularly
interesting we have this text the cynic
Epistles
which we'll talk about in just a bit
these are not actually
nobody really thinks these are by the
cynics that they're attributed to let
alone the other non-synic people like
say heraclitus
um or you know Socrates and the
socratics but we'll talk about that in a
bit
um and then we have this guy Julian the
emperor another late figure who writes a
couple orations that are important so
you know where can we get these texts
most of them are available
quite easily online you can find them
I'm going to provide a listing in the
video description about you know who you
should read and where you can get them
this one you'd have to actually purchase
because they haven't succeeded in
finding it online the cynic Epistles but
maybe some of you could be more
enterprising so these are some important
things to keep in mind we don't have a
lot of early original texts we do have
original texts from later authors and we
do have a lot of what we might call
doxographies or testimonies and you know
how reliable are all of these well
that's a question we're going to put off
for later
so my suggestions about where to start
would include
several sets of recommendations I've
already mentioned to you diogenes
Laertes lives of the philosopher book
six
and I've also mentioned xenophon
Symposium I think those are the places
where you should start now why should
you start there because what we're
getting are depictions of you know
antisthenes diogenes kratase some of the
other people who are in these circles
including you know Metro Place in a park
yeah brother and sister a park get
married to karates some of these other
more minor figures and we're getting it
reinforced with xenophon's depiction of
antisthenes and his connection to other
socratics so I think that is the the
very starting point for you and then
where do you go after that I would
actually suggest and this is probably
going to be kind of a controversial pick
that the third text that you ought to go
to
is a non-synic a stoic philosopher
Epictetus because he has in book three
of his discourses he has an entire
chapter in a long long chapter devoted
to the cynic way of life and he's
providing us with a not just depiction
of how the cynics live and saying ah
this is the Royal Road to Virtue and to
happiness
um but you know that's not for everybody
but he's also telling us what a cynics
think what are their key ideas so he's
presenting the cynic at their best you
might say now it is a later text right
so we're not as close to say krates and
and diogenes and and antestones if
anticines is indeed a cynic but we're
getting something that I think is quite
valuable and then after those I would
suggest
um you could go in a couple different
directions the direction that I would
actually suggest going in would be to go
to
um three main thinkers that are you know
from a later time so one of them I
mentioned well actually I've mentioned
all of these already the one that I
mentioned as an emperor Julian the
apostate Julian the emperor he's uh kind
of late and he's got these two very
interesting orations uh six and seven
six is to the uneducated cynics because
there are a lot of people who were
pretending to be cynics or they maybe in
their own mind they thought that being a
bomb and panhandling and you know just
talking smack to people was the cynic
way of life never washing all that kind
of stuff what we'd call these days kind
of you know dirty Neo hippies
um and he's talking he's trying to say
you're getting cynicism wrong cynicism
is is this Universal philosophy and he's
probably portraying it in the wrong way
right as many commentators will point
out it's an idealized picture of the
cynic but there are some very
interesting things in there
then we have the okra system who was
living as a cynic especially you know in
Exile wandering around and giving these
very very interesting orations to people
this is where we get a lot of the
stories of diogenes from actually so I
would uh read your way through as many
of his orations as you find interesting
it's perfectly fine to jump around and
Skip around because they're not in some
sort of you know thematic sequential
order or anything like that and then we
have one of my favorite authors of
ancient times Lucian of samsoda who is
kind of a skeptic kind of a cynic kind
of all over the map and he's primarily
interested in you know satirical work
which kind of fits into cynicism to some
degree
and he wrote a number of Works in which
the cynics play you know an important
role like the you know sale of the
philosophers but there's several other
works that I think are even more
important so we know about this cynic
demon ax
largely just through Lucian who wrote a
pangeiric a a praise of him which is
called the demon X there's also one
about a cynic that Lucian really didn't
like called peregrinus the death of
peregrinus and he seems to think that
like peregrinus was you know basically
putting on heirs and not not really
acidic or if he was he'd pick things up
by the wrong handle so to speak and then
there's one other piece
there's debate about whether this is
actually by Lucian or not it's called
the cynic and it presents
um you could call it an apologia a
justification on the part of the cynic
for their way of life against Lucian as
a Critic of them which is very very
interesting and so you put all these
works together we've got you know now
diogenes layer taste xenophon Epictetus
Julian the emperor Deo chrysostom and
Lucian and you're going to get a pretty
good picture about cynicism throughout
the ages I would also say that
it would be well worth getting your
hands on these cynic Epistles these are
circulating later on so long after these
people are passed away but these cynic
Epistles they're not probably by any of
the people that they're attributed to
but you can say there's certainly cynic
in their spirit and so what are we
getting in them I think the collections
that are attributed to crates
the third skolarc student of diogenes
and to diogenes are particularly
interesting helpful full of great ideas
about cynic philosophy there are also
Epistles of anacarsus in here who some
people think was like a protocynic right
he is a scythian who comes to Greece and
like you know explains their their uh
way of life and you know says a few
things but there's only 10 letters as
far as I remember in here by him so it's
not a huge selection then we get
Epistles from heraclitus definitely not
by heraclitus and Epistles of Socrates
and the socratics which are quite
interesting because they even include
um you know aristipus in there who's
definitely not a
um
not a not a cynic at all he's a hedonist
but these These are certainly well worth
checking out to understand cynicism and
then you know we have a few other
cynics that we learn about through
Reading other authors so I'll mention
um there's uh onamis right who we learn
about through the
um early church writer eusebius Who
quotes him uh quotes from his detection
of imposters at significant length in
chapter five of his church history
we learn about
onuscretus from strabo now he's a guy
who actually went off to India and
supposedly engaged with the gumnosophis
who might have been you know giant or
Buddhist or some sort of philosophers
and uh you know
compared their ways of life to each
other so that's preserved in strabo we
also find this guy Demetrius being
talked about in Seneca who is a stoic in
his on benefits book seven and in
Epistles 20 and 62. so you know sort of
tantalizing glimpses of more cynics
there's also discussions in Plutarch
here and there in the lives and you know
other places as well but I think those
would be you know sort of you've got
your beginner level stuff and then you
expand it to include the letters and
Julian and you know
um
Lucian and Deo criticism and then we've
got these other testimonies that could
be well worth reading and thinking about
so that's that's probably enough to get
you started
I do have some advice for you that is
based on the formats of the works that
we have to learn about cynicism from and
the first bit of advice that I had for
you is you know you don't have to take
any one of these works too seriously
they're not gospel truth you know like
something that you have to buy into and
believe or you're not a cynic you don't
know if you want to be a cynic yet right
so you know you read diogenes Laertes
did every single thing that he says
happen we don't know we'll never know
right unless we get to talk to diogenes
or antisthenes or krates or whoever else
themselves so you know you could kind of
take some of this with the proverbial
grain of salt but these are the best
things that we have for learning about
the cynics so you want to put aside any
absolute preoccupation with I have to be
completely certain about these these uh
philosophers you're not going to have
that and so you all the kinds of works
that we have we could say you know with
you know Epictetus Epictetus definitely
believe this or Lucian you know provided
Lucian actually wrote the things
attributed to them believe these sorts
of things but that's about it
um I think that another thing that might
be worth keeping in mind is that
cynicism
you know it's it's a practical
philosophy so you might actually get
some benefit out of
experimenting with the things that are
being put forward as cynic philosophy
I'm not saying you need to necessarily
go carry a pot of lentils across the
marketplace or anything like that but
you can do other things instead you
don't need to go and hug statues in
winter like diogenes did or throw away
your cup when you see a child scooping
up water in their hands but you can put
some of the basic ideas into practice
and see what happens you know and so you
know you can look at these texts as
being not just communicating what it is
that these people thought and did and
said but communicating a way of life
that you yourself could perhaps Embrace
in the present and there are a number of
people in the present that are carrying
out things kind of like this you know
all the emphasis on Simplicity on paring
things down that's kind of Quasi cynic
like I think that another thing that you
a lot to realize is that you are going
to find inconsistencies in these texts
you know for example crates in his
letters has a number of interesting bits
of advice and
explanations for who you should ask for
money or resources from and who you
shouldn't is his advice completely
consistent from letter to letter but
whoever the pseudocrates is well no not
exactly but you can kind of figure out
what the overall idea is and see if you
can piece together a coherent way of
life a coherent Doctrine something that
is you know perhaps not contradictory
but still has tensions within it that
requires thinking and application the
last thing I'll say about the format of
these is that every single one of these
texts is not written just to provide
objective
you know
no motive kind of truth about stuff
you're really not going to find that in
much philosophy at all and as a side
note anybody who tries to tell you that
they're giving you that is probably
selling you a line right
so each of these has a particular point
of view Julian the apostate or the
emperor is saying hey you dirty hippie
cynics over there you're not being like
real cynics you should direct yourself
back to this philosophy diocrisystem is
explaining you know his way of life and
cynic way of life and all sorts of
things to people in our rations
Epictetus is saying hey I'm a stoic but
if you want to take the short path
here's what it looks like don't embark
on it and embarrass yourself unless you
can actually do this diogenes Laertes
his his job as far as he sees it is to
tell you what it is that these people
said and did and you know what books
they wrote and what their doctrines and
way of life was and then let you figure
it out right so it gets even more like
this you know if we think about Seneca
who's a much less cynic stoic than
Epictetus is bringing up this guy
Demetrius right or you eusebius who is
clearly using this cynic who he's
quoting to try to bash the Greek
polytheists right so everybody's got an
agenda every text has got its own origin
and that also applies to the secondary
literature that we can read about it
which might be quite helpful for you as
well
so you know after you've read your way
through the primary texts as well as you
can or perhaps even you know along the
way you may want to delve into some of
the scholarship that is available about
cynicism and we're fortunate we've got
some pretty good stuff out there I will
highlight one book that I've actually
done a review of that is a fairly recent
book nice and short anscar Allen's
cynicism now this talks about ancient
cynicism and it also goes into
cynicism's Revival you know from
essentially the Renaissance onward and
into contemporary times super well
researched short Punchy to the point
very thought-provoking work another
important thinker is William Desmond and
I've got two books that I I recommend by
him so this is a you know less recent
but still fairly recent Book 2008 and
ancient philosophies cynics it's just
called cynics and it provides you with
sort of an overview of who were these
people what do we know about them and
then it goes into a bunch of very
interesting
chapters where it looks at Key ideas
renunciation of custom life according to
Nature chance fate fortune in the self
Anarchist Democrats Cosmopolitan Kings
and then cynic legacies like some of the
other texts it's got a glossary of Greek
terms which I think can be helpful for
you Desmond also has another very
interesting work the Greek Praise of
poverty origins of ancient cynicism so
this is a little bit more of a
comparative work and it's focusing in on
the you know life of poverty a
deliberate life of poverty putting aside
you know the pursuit of wealth and honor
and stuff like that and you know this
book as well is
um fairly recent 2006 so those are well
worth checking out I've got a few other
recommendations here
um
if you're interested in the connection
between cynicism and Christianity
there's a very recent book
translation of uh originally senior
season make christianism
you know cynicism and Christianity and
Antiquity by Marie Odell odile
gulakazam translated by Christopher
Smith really good put out by Aaron men's
ranges over all sorts of cool stuff
doesn't just talk about Christianity but
also ancient Greek and Roman religion
the talmud and all sorts of things like
that going back much further Donald
Dudley his history of cynicism I
actually like this quite a bit even
though I disagree with you know he
begins by the first chapter antisthenes
no direct connection with the cynics and
then attacks about his ethics but it
gives you like you know discussions of
each of these important sin next what
can we tell about them this is an older
work you know so 1937 but it's still
pretty pretty decent I would say and
then we have uh this wonderful volume
which includes a whole bunch of essays
the cynics the cynic movement in
Antiquity and its Legacy edited by we
just met her Marie O'Neil goulette Kaze
and R Brock Branham so it includes you
know Anthony long and
um uh a number of other important people
in here that you might recognize from
Hellenistic philosophy and there's all
sorts of really interesting things like
there's an article on anacarsus there's
a discussion of Aristo as we're going to
look at in in a bit uh cynicism and
Christianity from the Middle Ages to the
Renaissance you know the modern
reception of cynicism so that is well
worth getting and then I think this is a
good one too classical cynicism a
critical study by Louise the Navia from
Greenwood press this is a little bit
more dated 1996 but it talks about where
cynicism is coming from it's got
chapters on antisines diogenes kratase
and then Hellenistic and Roman cynicism
so those are you know there's other good
secondary literature out there you find
lots of Articles as well but those are
the book length study and I think you're
you're going to be
able to find some of these fairly easily
in not just you know college and
university libraries but decent
um public libraries as well particularly
you know uh William Desmond and his work
so those are some of the secondary lit
things that I would suggest there's also
you know plenty of resources online that
you can find including my own videos
about about the cynics so that might be
a way to start with contemporary work on
the cynics from the last century or so
there are some problems and issues that
do arise within the scholarship that I
don't think you need to be overly
concerned about as somebody who's
engaged in self-directed study so you
know I'll start with one that's very
trivial right so Plato had his Academy
Aristotle had his lyceum the epicureans
had the garden the snow the stoics have
obviously had the stowa point where did
the cynics hang out did they really hang
out in the kunosargas
well antisthenes probably did use it it
was for
non-citizens right
but there wasn't a lot of like cynic
teaching going on there so that's that's
kind of a non-starter I don't think you
need to worry about mapping everything
in ancient Athens or anything like that
some people really do get quite what
worked up about that another one that I
don't think you need to be super super
concerned with is this vexed question
throughout the scholarship
was antisthenes the first cynic or was
diogenes the first cynic you know and
there's arguments being given back and
forth for the two of them if antistanes
wasn't the first cynic he certainly was
influential on it you could call him a
protocynic whatever you want to do I'm
perfectly happy with the Orthodox
succession of Socrates to antisthenes
who then is doing his own thing diogenes
coming along maybe or maybe not being
educated by antisthenes depending on how
we date things but certainly
intensifying and expanding cynicism and
then just as important as diogenes
kratase you know the supposed third
skolarc
um known for his philanthropia love of
humanity showing us a different way to
be a cynic that doesn't involve
masturbating in the marketplace right I
don't think you have to be overly
concerned about this succession you know
and this leads us into another really
important issue
there's a lot of people very concerned
not just with the cynics but also with
Socrates or with religious figures like
Jesus or the Buddha or Confucius how
much of this is historically reliable
and we don't know you know
um the issue isn't really did diogenes
say every single one of these things
that are attributed to him or did
karates write any of these letters
that's not really the the main concern
the I you know the idea is being
conveyed the issues all of these sorts
of things the way of life that is being
presented that's really what we're
interested in here so I don't think you
have to worry too much about that
another one that comes up as well is
cynicism just a way of life or a
practice so maybe I don't need to read
any of these texts at all I should be
out there being diogenes in the
marketplace well first of all diogenes
isn't the only cynic or the only way of
being a cynic and you know this kind of
goes with any philosophy of life you
can't adequately do a philosophy as a
way of life that's distinctive and
faithful to whatever you're claiming to
be whether it's stoicism epicureanism
cynicism aristotelianism whatever it
Whatever It Is without actually engaging
with the text the literature the
teachings the ideas there's a dialectic
that goes back and forth between them so
there are some people out there that
might be troubling you by saying oh you
don't need to read anything as a matter
of fact it's a bad idea for you to do
that I just don't listen to them you
don't have to be concerned with those
people they're not actually speaking
truth to power they're not practicing
any helpful parasia they're just uh
justifying their own you know acting
like a bomb they would be the ones that
Julia and the emperor is criticizing and
then finally the last one I think you
don't really have to be super concerned
with besides antisthenes who's really a
cynic is anacarsus the scythian acinic
acidicism isn't around at the time you
know they are the cynics looked to him
as like a sage they also thought
Hercules was somebody they could bring
in you don't have to be super concerned
about that you know determining one way
or the other
aristos of kiosk another person
potentially a cynic we don't really know
we don't we we don't have enough about
him so you don't have to like worry
about who's in the Box who's outside of
the box there isn't any box right here
you're literally thinking outside of the
box with this there is a continuity
there is a literature there is a way of
life and you will do better to put all
these worries aside for the moment until
you've read your way around the text and
perhaps read some of the secondary
literature where very smart people are
grappling with these questions
all right so final thoughts I myself am
not a cynic but I think that it is quite
valuable to study the cynic school
they're very interesting to look at and
compare very influential on other
schools both in Antiquity and in
modernity so you know it's if you're
going to engage in a fairly uh
comprehensive curriculum you will not
want to ignore the cynics that said
they're also still kind of a minor
school we don't have as much from them
as we do say Plato and Aristotle and
their successors or even the stoics or
the epicureans but they are definitely
well worth digging into and I hope that
this video has given you some helpful
suggestions or lines to carry out your
own inquiry and that you will continue
on with your own path working on your
own self-directed study in philosophy
that will include the cynic School